there's this popular program called
stranger things on TV
and as a fan and as a physicist I've
come up with a theory and just for
warning there's going to be some
spoilers
[Music]
in stranger things one of the characters
will gets trapped in this sort of
parallel universe called the upside down
and when he's trapped there his mum is
you know really worried about him but
she figures out that he's not missing
and actually she can communicate with
him when he's in this parallel universe
and she does it by stringing up some
Christmas lights on the wall and under
each light bulb she writes a letter and
so from this parallel universe the kid
manages to light up a light bulb above a
letter and spell out a message to his
mum like a high-tech Ouija board yeah
basically and so I was thinking as a
physicist
how is this even possible how does one
communicate from a whole other Universe
to our universe in 1983
and so I've come up with this Theory
this physics fan Theory and I think that
this is possible if
this parallel universe called the upside
down is quantumly entangled with our
universe
I guess we got to understand quantum
entanglement first first of all you've
got to get rid of everything that you
know about the classical world so in the
classical world this is a Red Bull and
it will always be a Red Bull similarly
this is a blue ball and this will always
be a blue ball and if I sort of shuffle
them round and hold one in either hand
when I say to you know which one is the
red ball and which one is the blue ball
we know that one of them is definitely
red and one of them is definitely blue
and so it's only when I open my hand and
say okay that was the blue ball and that
was the red ball that we knew all along
that this was blue and this was red
but one of them is always blue one of
them is always red
if this was the quantum worlds and you
couldn't tell which one was red or which
was blue
they would both be red and blue at the
same time
so this is like the Schrodinger's cat
example the cat is both dead and alive
at the same time they're both purple
with purple yes they are
um so there's some sort of weird linear
superposition of red and blue in the
quantum world and it's only when we
again we open the hand and we see that
this one is blue that we know this one
it's red but before that they were both
so if we have two quantumly entangled
particles instead in this weird quantum
mechanical World these can have sort of
any property so what I was doing there
was this color was an analogy for spin
basically or some property of the
particle so spin up and spin down and
that is a very fundamental property of
particles and so if we have these
quantumly entangled particles they don't
have any spin yet all right so they do
have spin it's just that you can't
describe one without describing the
other okay so they're in this weird
superposition state where they can be
both spin up and spin down but the thing
about quantumly entangled particles is
that as soon as you measure them and one
becomes spin up the other one
immediately become come spin down so
whatever one of them does the other one
has to do the exact opposite and that's
what quantum entanglement is poor will
trapped in this parallel universe if
this entire universe was quantumly
entangled with our universe then
anything that will does in the parallel
universe has to be reflected in our
universe as well the particles have to
do the exact opposite so say we'll take
the light bulb in the parallel universe
of the upside down and maybe put a
battery to it and force the electrons in
that light bulb to move around a circuit
he would have given the momentum in a
direction and therefore the particles in
our universe would have to do the exact
opposite so that mean they would also
have to have momentum but in the
opposite direction and therefore also
move around a circuit and therefore
light up a light bulb so if he lit up a
light bulb in his Universe the light
bulb would also light up in our universe
but wouldn't also will himself have to
be in both universes and wouldn't when
he moves the battery wouldn't the whole
Factory have to float in the other
Universe yeah no this is where this sort
of theory is a little bit like we're
gonna have to think about this uh I mean
I'm also assuming that you know these
light bulbs are in parallel you know
they're not in series in in the in their
circuit they're in parallel I mean this
is 1983 they could be in series I don't
know this is the kind of thing that you
have to assume all the way that you go
through this Theory but you're saying if
the upside down is a parallel universe
you can manipulate the electrons in his
he'll be able to manipulate electrons in
the other exactly through quantum
entanglement that's my theory foreign
would you like to hear how this theory
is absolutely rubbish so there are many
problems but so as a scientist I had to
think through these problems and go
through them the first question I had
was is it even possible to make a
quantumly entangled Universe because
that just seems ridiculous in my head
turns out not so ridiculous so I
actually found a paper quantum
entanglement in the Multiverse and this
is you know a theoretical paper but
they're actually talking about it as if
we could measure whether this has
actually happened in our own universe so
what they're saying is if our universe
is one of many and the Multiverse Theory
holds that there are many many universes
then after the big bang 10 to the minus
36 seconds after the big bang to be
precise there was this period of time
called inflation where the universe
rapidly inflated in the space of sort of
from 10 to the minus 36 to sort of like
10 to the minus 33 seconds so a very
very short space of time inflated very
rapidly and that has like loads of
consequences on sort of how the universe
is today because any sort of teeny tiny
fluctuations in the particles that were
created just after the big bang were
sort of locked in so density
fluctuations anything like that were
then spread out over these huge
distances and that meant that then some
areas of the universe are more dense
than the others and that's how you ended
up getting galaxies forming there et
cetera et cetera so they're saying if
you have inflation in the Multiverse and
you're creating sort of child universes
from say our parent universe so lots of
multiverses are sort of springing off
and you have inflation then the same
properties are going to be imprinted in
one universe as in the child universe as
well like an identical twin so that's
what inflation would do it would imprint
both those things and if you had two
particles that work in these Quantum the
entanglement state in the beginning then
they will be quantumly entangled in
these two separate universities the
really cool thing about this paper is
that they suggest that actually if this
was true in our universe you'd actually
be able to test whether that was true
because these kind of quantum
entanglement fluctuations that would be
imprinted in inflation you'd still be
able to see in what's called The Cosmic
microwave background which is this
microwave signal which is a remnant of
the Big Bang in the very early stages of
the universe where light could first
escape from the early stages of the
universe so
I think that's really exciting and the
fact that my crazy fan Theory could
actually you know in our own Universe
could exist
I was like that was that was one point
to me that's one point there is another
problem and it's something called
quantum decoherence
if you have two quantumly entangled
particles and you want to send a message
between the two of them say you're doing
it for like encryption or something and
you move one particle say you know 300
miles away and you measure one thing to
have a certain span of momentum and
therefore the other one has to do the
exact opposite this is what Einstein was
really concerned about you were there
for sending a message faster than the
speed of light because as soon as this
one is measured This One automatically
changes and so that is sort of this
spooky action at a distance and we know
that things can't travel faster than the
speed of light people have got around
that now by saying well I had to
physically move this 300 miles away
first to send that message and I
couldn't have made that travel faster
than the speed of light therefore the
message itself didn't travel faster than
the speed of light because if I move
that you know very very close to the
speed of light say 99 of the speed of
light over here and then I transfer that
message
transfer a message back
then that has trouble faster than the
speed of light
but that's not possible so as soon as I
measure this one uh spin up and this one
has been down that is an irreversible
process and the reason for that is
you've had to put energy into this
system okay so you've had to say okay
this one has to be spent up this one has
to be spin down and what you've done is
you've put energy into the universe this
has somehow interacted with the
environment that it's in and with the
universe and you've increased the
entropy of the universe so for those of
you who are paying attention in school
that should raise a little red flag the
second law of Thermodynamics says that
you cannot decrease the entry of the
universe so we've increased the entropy
by doing that measurement and measuring
to say that yes this one has been up and
this one is spin down and so you cannot
reverse that process because reversing
it you would have to decrease the
entropy of the universe to do that so
any interaction with your environment
breaks quantum entanglement so what does
that mean in terms of my crazy fan
Theory as soon as will has moved the
electrons and set up the circuit in one
light bulb he couldn't do it again in
that same light bulb so when his mum has
strung up the lights with a single
letter under every single light
he won't be able to use the same letter
twice so you have to get very creative
with his lettering
and in the show he writes the words
right here
so he uses e twice and therefore I don't
think my theory holds because he
wouldn't be able to use e twice under
our understanding of quantum
entanglement and Quantum decoherence he
always say uses R and H twice isn't he
right here yeah okay okay I'll do that
one again
I was like here is fine yeah
so I could influence his thoughts for
example how would I influence his
thoughts well I'd have to change the
biochemistry and what's the biochemistry
about it's about electrons so somehow my
electrons would have to couple they'd
have to become strongly Quantum
mechanically entangled with Brady's
electrons